no way what's like imagine dating
I'm not even dating saying you've known
this girl for like six years you thought
the world of hurt right and then all of
a sudden like after like six or seven
years you found out about account would
you look at that person differently or
would he just be like oh yes are you
just dating her for six years I see like
you're married or anything like even I
see you say even like she's your
girlfriend right
and you've known her for six years this
is like has that happened to you no okay
so six years it's very specific
Thursday she says yeah but it's like
after so long would you look at that
person differently knowing that oh what
it costs like 50 or something you know
you would there's no way in hell that
you wouldn't that you would you may not
say anything but in the back of your
mind it's all gonna be thinking oh my
God she's slept with that many men and
then you're now gonna start looking at a
differently so what then tends to happen
is that you might now she might say I'm
going to have my friends so when she was
doing it before you were fine but when
she's now doing it and she's told you a
number you're thinking oh is
where she where are you going
particularly like what are you gonna do
yep it's an ego thing yeah okay you know
I don't see you asleep
that's a secret that's quite a secret to
her I'm just thinking 15 that way you
can't could you go anywhere and not run
it like is this like the law of
something where you're like five
connections away from everybody is that
a thing yeah it is yeah
so I'm like a 50. did you guys run into
like like men she slept with well we
would we would go to sporting events and
see them playing sports so that was like
kind of weird and you know it's always
the same conversation it's like oh now
that you know like you don't think it's
highly of me cry cry I'm like no no no
it's fine I don't care about your past
of course I'm gonna say it because I
want more mind-blowing sucks but I'm not
gonna put a ring on it because remember
market value is not determined but I
want to do data for about six seven
months okay and then you broke it off
um she'd reappear occasionally in my
life since then I mean up until like you
know up until I got very serious with
somebody right you see I was business is
business
you could have dated her for six years
her thinking you're gonna marry her you
knowing that you would but I wasn't
gonna do that I don't know but I'm just
saying women don't realize that a man
can date you for years and have
absolutely no intention of marrying you
he's just waiting until he finds that
woman that he will marry and we don't
really know that but that's true women
women do the same they do and I think
they're science anyway I don't think I
think that's that's you're describing
hypergamy that's actually very female
Behavior women no no I mean
no I don't mean that
no no actually I actually agree with him
because women leave more we leave like
80 of the time I don't mean leaving I
just mean that a man have you not had
boyfriends that now you look back you
think actually I thought I broke up with
him but he was never gonna marry me you
weren't you weren't you weren't his
girlfriend you just learned that they
weren't your boyfriend
well it's like if a woman is giving up
like oh we're dating but it's like well
are you dating or are you right no I've
only ever had like relationship well
I've had a situation but you know
what I mean is
you might think as a girl that you're
dating this guy and you may even live
together but that still doesn't mean he
has any intention of actually marrying
you and you don't know that that's what
happened to you
not what like the the dating someone for
a long time when you know I've had
several relationships that now I look
back I think actually that was never
going anywhere either I always thought
it was me deciding that but then you
think actually he never was going to
propose it was time wasting men can
waste time yeah did he did he end up
like marrying someone else right after
or did they never get married
um a couple of my exes I think are
married Yeah
because sometimes I think it's like
girls will try to make a guy that
doesn't want to be a husband a husband
yeah I mean he's just not a husband so I
was just curious of the guys like were
they not husbands or like they were
never gonna marry you to me they weren't
I don't actually think they were
husbands I wasn't happy but
they may well be now this was obviously
I'm 35 this was in my 20s early 20s
um
I think that women date potential so me
dating someone at my own age at that
point might have been the problem I've
I've not really dated older I've not
really I've been a bit weird about it
but actually maybe that's a better idea
not now my my fiance's younger
but I'm just saying that uh
do you know if a guy doesn't get married
after the age of 35 he only has a 15
chance of ever getting married am I
crazy
for women it's like zero percent oh wow
no I think what is it by if a woman
doesn't if a woman doesn't have a child
by 35 the chances of her having a child
drop to about zero well she's single by
30 the chance of her the chance that if
she's single at 30 the chance of her
ever having like a kid drops below 50
right so you're like she's more likely
to not have a kid than have one what
does that tell you about sexual market
value of a woman no that's a scary
statistic right that's a harsh reality
for me I'm getting married I would like
to have kids my partner would like to
have kids but I am 35 and the chances
and I think that should be taught to to
girls because at the moment you see a
lot of celebrities they've played for
IVF they've had their Expos and they're
doing it older but they've got millions
of pounds to achieve things that isn't
actually easy to achieve in the real
world what do you wish you knew at 25
uh not to date anybody for potent for
their potential because the chances of
them fulfilling that potential are quite
slim
um that actually a man who is a
go-getter a man that is a hard worker
driven they already are and it's not
going to come from me pushing them they
already are that person and then yeah
would you say you dated more for like
looks in your 20s
not based on my exes no but I I do think
that that's what you look for definitely
um I think but I've
I've
sort of
oh sorry me
this way sorry it's because I'm looking
at Pearl that's why
um
it's me
uh I lost where I was again I asked if
you you dated for looks in your 20s
because not based on my exes no but I do
think that uh Charisma I'd say I went
for the funny one the loud one The
Confident one you know they weren't
always the best looking one but but I
think that that comes off as like a
masculinity in a way so I think that's
what I was attracted to
um and then I'd get in the relationship
and realize actually they weren't doing
anything else and I stood Your Hooks
they had a lot of practice to get that
funny a lot of free time exactly yeah
yeah yeah yeah
okay um what did you think of the body
count uh when does is high value off the
table for a woman I think it is uh
slightly age-related as well
um I think that if I had a kid or a
niece well I do have a niece I would say
just hold on to your virginity for as
long as you can
um but I think that early 18 if you
start having sex when you're 16 maybe
you've slept with one person and then 20
maybe two you know and then if you're 35
and you've had a few relationships and
it'll be a little bit above but I think
that there's no need to go out
yeah I think what's the what's the
number oh sorry yeah sorry
uh so
early 20s I'd say like five okay what
are you just high value off the table
for a woman probably 25 okay so so save
five then okay roughly five five twenty
five
yeah
uh what do you think yeah I think five
five yeah five after five high values
Lots sorry
I'll say below double digits to be
honest below okay you're kind you'll
give it
[Music]
that's the most common answer I get I
get like yeah 10 is well I I get when I
ask how many bodies is Too Many Bodies
it's always prefer five I'll deal with
ten
15 maybe if she's hot yeah
well it's funny that a lot of people
land on five that's like statistically
kind of the average for women in the
western Nations like and so you're kind
of going well as long as she's kind of
average which is you know I think it's a
fair standard average now that is about
the average yeah reported I mean
obviously there's going to be some
variances because people lie whatever
but on the grand scale it's probably not
off by more than one the one I the one I
read was higher than that it was like
eight I think that might have been like
Sweden or something like a really like
egalitarian sort of open society that
could happen for me you know so and uh
were you doing like world yeah okay no
it's more Western world it's more like
England America Canada you know like
sort of like the G20 whatever you want
to call it so there there could be you
know some variance in that but
that's good though if the average is
five it's a it's such a it's such an
interesting thing let me tell you guys
this like here's a question I would ask
right and here's a like a legitimate
statistical question I'm interested in
this right
as a man's income and options go up
options meaning more women are willing
to sleep with them therefore he gets to
choose who he wants to commit to because
that's what a man does at the end of
time out he chooses who he commits to
right he's the one that controls the
commitment the woman controls the sex
right as a man's options go up does that
number change
an interesting question because like
the the body count for a girl that's
acceptable to him to form a long-term
relationship like I know a dude we
actually both know a dude with Henry
that like is with the check right now
and like you can tell she's been with a
lot of dudes but the guy's so
inexperienced and naive he's just happy
to have a woman he's like yeah I have a
woman is he well off or no no no no no
no no not at all but I'm thinking like
but I'm thinking like if this guy was
like as this guy right he's young but as
he rises through life he's like you know
he makes more money more money more so
whatever that metric you use for Value
whatever whatever you know gains more
opportunity more more social value
he might look at that chick and be like
you know what I can do better
you know be it's like the same that your
friend is picking up a 300 pound check
it's like most of the guys that go for
that by the way there's actual studies
on this as well right and they say that
poorer men prefer fatter women and I
look at that study ago it's not that
they prefer it's just who they can get
it's just like the market has a certain
equilibrium right there's a surplus so
that there's way too many chicks that
are oversized and there's way too many
lazy broke ass dudes and then the market
Surplus adjusts itself oh yeah they're
really a match made in heaven Heaven's a
strong word
Heaven's a strong word but that's funny
because this lady in the green dress
here was saying like yeah I had some
guys living with me that never really
thought they were going to marry me and
my first thought was like I wonder if
they're a very low ambition men
yeah because they're comfortable being
in an imperfect situation what happens
is in this young gentleman here in front
of me in the matching suit he was saying
earlier he's like I want a girl that
that pushes me to and motivates me and
I'm like no you don't if a woman has to
motivate you if no you don't if a woman
issue then if a woman has to motivate
you in a relationship you will both be
better and resentful encourages I agree
with that yeah I agree with you like
like my woman is like hey do you need to
travel on that trip do you do this I'm
like yeah like you know like I I told my
girlfriend who became my wife I was like
I'm really really ambitious gonna be
working all the time you have to deal
with that if you don't that's okay but
that's gonna be me and so and I find
that her attraction for me uh stabilizes
and even goes up because I am achieving
new things all the time as many of you
know I was just banned on Tick Tock and
we are demonetized on a daily basis on
this platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible